Democrats may have won the house but
Trumpy Bear is winning holiday shopping
season and my heart we examine the
historical brilliance of the latest
political stocking stuffer that is
making plush toys great again then a
potential cabinet shake-up at the White
House a pro-taliban Democrat belatedly
wins the Senate seat in Arizona and the
majority of Democrats think Republicans
are racist sexist and bigoted finally
Michelle Obama Jada Pinkett Smith and
Mark Zuckerberg show us the difference
between real and imagined oppression I'm
Michael Knowles and this is the Michael
Knowles Oh
[Music]
oh so much to get to today you know as
the inventor of last year's political
stocking stuffer the blank book reasons
to vote for Democrats I'm gonna take all
the money that I made on that and spend
every single penny of it on
Trumpy bears the greatest product the
greatest product in at least 12 months
before we do that we got to talk about
one more excellent product that is
bowline branch sheets these all actually
have presidential tie-ins bowline branch
is absolutely phenomenal I love them
they have helped to save my marriage you
know especially you fit them on that
nice new mattress it's it's wonderful I
didn't realize this when I was a
bachelor and I would spend about five
dollars on a set of sheets but it turns
out that they actually have nice sheets
that you can buy and when you want to
buy premium sheets if you go to a store
they'll cost a thousand dollars
sometimes or more a bowl and branch
though by cutting out the middleman can
get you a really really good deal on
them made from pure 100% organic cotton
they start out super soft and they get
even softer over time you buy directly
from them so you're essentially paying
wholesale prices luxury sheets can cost
up to a thousand bucks but you won't do
that on Bowen branch that is why they
have thousands of five-star reviews
Forbes Wall Street Journal Fast Company
are all talking about them three u.s.
presidents sleep on bull and branch
sheets maybe Trumpy Bear does - I don't
know statistically they must have a few
Trumpy bears on there
shipping is free you can try 330 Nights
if you don't love them send them back
for a refund but I doubt you'll want to
send them back there's no risk and no
reason not to kaboom try to get started
right now my listeners get $50 off your
first set of sheets at Boland branch
calm promo code Michael mi CH AE L go to
Boleyn branch calm today for $50 off
your first set of sheets that is bol L
and branch calm promo code Michael mi CH
AE L Boland branch calm promo code
Michael okay now from that product to
Trumpy bear the product that is sweeping
the nation if you haven't seen the
commercial I pity you check it out I am
the store
the great American grizzly introducing
the original Trumpy bear the fearless
Super Plus American grizzly
Trumpy bear was born June 4
flagged a just find the secret zipper
and pull out the flag blanket then wrap
yourself in the red white and blue for
comfort and warm show your patriotism
and proudly displayed frumpy on Flag Day
and on any American holiday
Trumpy can even honor your own family
heroes god Bless America and God bless
Trumpy bear
god bless Trumpy bear absolutely right
some people have wondered if this is
real or not when I first saw the ad I
was convinced it was a joke it was just
satire
oh no 100% real it's produced by a
company called exceptional products
because what other company would produce
this it was invented by a guy named VL
lang here's what he said when he was a
lot of media reached out to him they
said this can't possibly be real it is
he said quote this iconic bear should be
viewed as the symbol that anyone can run
for president of this great country of
ours the weight of the responsibilities
that come with the presidency can be a
burden that I for one could never endure
so one thing I like about this I don't
know if this guy is saying this
intentionally or not but the joke is
he's made this bear about how great
Trump is and yet what are you saying it
symbolizes is that anybody even Donald
Trump can run for president in his
statement about it it's actually sort of
an insult to president Trump but there
is something to that not that he's
unqualified to be President but that
he's not the sort of presidential
candidate that we are used to getting
and Trumpy bear is not new it didn't
just come out this week and I think they
aired some commercials on Fox News which
is when everybody saw it but it has been
out since last October and so people are
enjoying the camp of it it's such an
obviously sticky kind of kitschy toy
okay that's great it actually makes a
lot of historical sense though because
it's the Donald Trump teddy bear but the
teddy bear is named after another
Republican president it's named after
Teddy Roosevelt the teddy bear got its a
named after Teddy Roosevelt you know
till he was a fairly manly guy a lot of
much she's mo he would go out hunting
and in 1902 he was on a hunt with his
buddies and he didn't get a bear they
were out hunting black bears I believe
and he just they found a bear but Teddy
wasn't
to grab it so these guys went and they
beat up the bear they clubbed it they
tied it to a tree and then they said
okay mister mr. Roosevelt you can go out
and shoot the bear now but he said oh
that's not very sportsman like if I just
have a bear tied up to a tree and then I
shoot it in the head he did say however
that because the bear was injured they
should put it out of its misery but that
he wasn't going to do it and so created
this scene that then was drawn out in a
lot of political cartoons in newspapers
around the country which I think the
first one was by Clifford Berryman in
the Washington Post and it's this
cartoon of Teddy Roosevelt walking away
you know saying I'm not gonna shoot this
bear and I suppose it depends on how you
look at the cartoon either it's he's
saying I'm not going to do it you do my
dirty work for me or he's having some
mercy on this old bear which is actually
what he was doing and so there were
multiple versions of this cartoon
produced and over time the bear got
cuter and cuter and cuddly or cuddly and
then this businessman came out and he
said he already made a couple toys it
bears and he'd called them teddy bears
and he put them on for sale in his store
they became extremely popular the White
House actually gave him permission to
use the name
Teddy's bears and so he sells the teddy
bears it they then creates a toy company
out of it it becomes hugely popular it's
still popular today a few things I
really like about this one it shows
Republican compassion - it's about
another Republican president and three
it involves colluding with the Russians
which is a little historical to admit I
think people are not appreciating out of
this so a lot of people on the left and
the right are not understanding the
marketing of Trumpy bear what they're
seeing is ridiculous thing you know Ben
yesterday tweeted out this it was two
circles perfectly lined up over one
another and it said it was a Venn
diagram of people who bought Michael
Knowles's book and people who are going
to buy Trumpy bear it's just a perfect
circle you know which led me to decide
that I'm going to create a plush Ben
Shapiro bear called grumpy bear but
that's neither here and over there so I
you know I think what Ben is seeing
obviously is that there's this sort of
exuberance this sort of giddiness about
it absolutely right it's sort of like
the make America
again hat the make America great again
had it's not that it's this sleek
stylish hat it's actually sort of the
opposite of stylish it's a hat that
looks like it was made in the early
nineteen nineties big block letters
nothing subtle about it kind of a
golfcourse hat you know doesn't not not
any kind of special design but it's
there's just something about it that is
so bold
that's so in a sense manly that you got
to buy it even back when I didn't like
Donald Trump the candidate when I was
gonna vote for Ted Cruz I still bought
the Hat I love the Hat it's the same
thing I'm obviously gonna get a trump II
bear because Trump in many ways is like
Teddy Roosevelt this boisterous
larger-than-life figure Teddy Roosevelt
was a war hero he was maybe a little
more extreme than Trump in that
Roosevelt just started random Wars and
was always agitating for Wars to make
the country man there but still giant
personalities people who constantly were
talking about the strenuous life and
going out there and making a lot of
money and working hard and all okay so
we got all of that and the other that
final aspect is with Trump and Roosevelt
you get this carry a big stick
always have the credible threat of force
and always be negotiating from a
position of strength but be merciful to
that that's the other important point
here you know Teddy's got that black
bear up against a tree all tied up he
could kill him and he says no I'm not
gonna shoot him I don't want it that's
not sportsman like Donald Trump has
China up against a wall on trade this
season oh we're not gonna have a trade
where I want to get to no tariffs there
there is something to be said for
negotiating from a position of strength
Ronald Reagan said it he said you get
peace through strength and we know that
President Trump has taken lines from
Reagan before make America great again
as a Reagan line he learns from these
great figures of Republican history and
I hope that this is another example of
that and I can't wait for all of my
stockings to be stuffed with Trump II
Bears this coming Christmas speaking of
the Trump administration the real Trump
administration not the bear Trump
administration we may be heading for a
shake-up at the White House now I always
temper these because the main
stream media get this wrong constantly
but according to reports from multiple
sources
I think stemming from the Washington
Post the department of homeland security
secretary kirsten nielsen may be on her
way out we've heard this before but
there has been a huge rise in illegal
immigration over the past year that said
there's been a huge increase in arrests
as well but it seems that the president
may not be pleased with her performance
she is the third Department of Homeland
Security secretary in just two years if
she is kicked out before her first year
is even up then you know there will be
four in two years that is a lot it
probably shows one the mismanagement of
the Department of Homeland Security it's
kind of a hodgepodge agency that was
created after September 11th and it
includes facets of a couple of other
agencies and it's never really seemed to
gain a surer footing and the other
aspect is how difficult it is to enforce
our immigration law because that's what
President Trump is upset about that was
the campaign promise and the question is
why are so many people still coming into
the country why are we seeing record
high illegal immigration into the
country the highest month on record was
last month
why can't we build the wall what what is
taking so long so he seems to be getting
tired of her the other aspect of her
getting kicked out that for people
watching the tea leaves is a little
worrisome is that she is a John Kelly
girl so Kirsten Nielsen was the previous
White House principal deputy chief of
staff under John Kelly so she's working
right under John Kelly reports are
saying that John Kelly is fighting for
her to remain at DHS and yet there are
other reports coming in which we've
heard now for months and months and
months that John Kelly is on his way out
that he's going to be kicked out and
this is not just what we're hearing from
CNN in the Washington Post I've heard
this from sources in the White House
outside the White House who knows what
they're trying to do or they're trying
to sow discord they're trying to spread
misinformation are they sending out
leaks specifically at the behest of the
people who can make the decisions what's
going on I'm not sure but I actually
will defend the media on this one I've
been hearing the same things - and yet
here we are how much later in John Kelly
still is in the job and it's
that John Kelly has done a pretty good
job as chief of staff he brought order
to that administration let's not forget
how chaotic it was before he came in
there
he brought order to it and so I I hope
he's not gone if he's gone c'est la vie
but but let's hope that this Kirsten
Nielsen move is not indicative of that
because it's perfectly normal
listen after midterm elections it's
perfectly normal for there to be an exit
at the White House also when President
Trump has replaced people I think
virtually all of them he's replaced with
people who were better at the job than
the previous people that's not to
denigrate Sean Spicer or anything he's a
he was very good at his job but Sarah
Sanders is excellent at that job as well
so John Bolton obviously was a huge
upgrade and national security adviser so
I'm not despairing but that said I think
John Kelly has done a great job and so I
hope that they don't they don't boot him
out of there the rumor by the way has
been the Trump is looking to replace
John Kelly with Nick Ayers he is the
chief of staff to Vice President Mike
Pence again this is all court intrigue
this is all gossip and having heard it
from people at 1600 Pennsylvania and
from people in the media as well I just
don't really believe it I don't think
there's a ton of credibility to these
anymore but we'll see what happens there
has been a lot of talk about Nielsen
leaving now and if it's gonna happen
it's gonna happen right now after the
midterm elections speaking of the
midterm elections they're still going on
did you know that I know that you
thought that they were last Tuesday
they're still going on they're gonna be
going on for another couple of years
probably we're gonna have midterm
elections the 2018 midterm elections
during the 2022 midterm elections in
Arizona Republican martha mcsalley has
just conceded to socialists pro-taliban
lunatic Kyrsten Sinema when I say
pro-taliban lunatic that's I'm not just
being hyperbolic she suggested after
September 11th that it would be fine for
Americans to go fight for the Taliban
that that's who just beat martha
mcsalley
who I believe is the first female pilot
to fly in combat the first American
female pilot to fly in combat all-around
incredible great patriotic Camaro
and just lost a Kyrsten Sinema so how
did mcsalley take it well you know I
mean we've seen what's happened in
Florida what's happened in Georgia all
these Democrats demanding recounts
unconcealed
saying they're gonna fight tooth and
nail what does mcsalley do she
gracefully and politely concedes here
she is everybody I just called Kyrsten
Sinema and congratulated her on becoming
Arizona's first female senator after a
hard-fought battle I wish her all
success says she represents Arizona in
the Senate and I also want to say thank
you to everybody who supported me in
this campaign my staff and volunteers
and everybody who voted for me I'm so
grateful for you as my wingman and my
wing women in this journey we sure wish
it came out with a different result but
I'm so thankful for you as I traveled
around this state I was so inspired by
the many people that I met and I am
convinced Arizona is the best state in
the country and our best days are still
yet to come and I'm going to continue to
pray for our success thank you so much
she is convinced that Arizona is the
best state in the country okay so that's
graceful beautiful hopeful talking about
you know how great her constituents are
okay now let's compare that to the woman
who actually won the race Kyrsten Sinema
take it away as we see in this very
quote that the states are the
laboratories of democracy and then my
state Arizona is clearly the meth lab of
democracy
yeah and I cannot take credit for that
line someone at the Daily Show wrote it
but I'm happy to steal it and use it all
the time so one says Arizona is just a
great wonderful place and all the people
are terrific in it so they don't vote
for that woman they vote for the woman
who calls Arizona the meth-lab of
democracy this is pretty troubling and
it's troubling for a few reasons one how
did cinema win was there voter fraud
maybe voter fraud happens all around the
country absolutely could be we've seen
videos in this midterm elections of poll
workers saying that illegal aliens are
encouraged to vote we've got the video
you can't deny it
don't tell me to disbelieve my own lyin
eyes we've seen people say we've seen in
Florida a Democrat operatives have just
discovered random boxes of provisional
ballots that only vote for Democrat
candidates who are in trouble okay so
could there be voter fraud yeah
absolutely there are plenty of people
who are registered to vote in two
different states registered to vote
where they shouldn't be registered to
vote where they don't live I guess it
could be that or I'd actually be happier
if it were caused by voter fraud perhaps
the more troubling thing is that Arizona
is tilting Democrat it's a red state
it's been a red state I don't think it's
been represented by a Democrat in the
Senate for 30 years now however if you
look at just the number of registered
Democrats and Republicans it's almost
equal Republicans still have a very very
slight advantage but it's almost equal
now and this is a real worrying trend
because it seems that the more and more
Democrats who were in that state the
more likely it is that you're going to
lose good patriotic candidates like
martha mcsalley you know first female
pilot to fly in combat and you're going
to get someone who literally is
supporting the Taliban even John McCain
I mean say what you will about his
politics which were basically awful but
the guy was an American Hero he did
fight for his country was patriotic to
the end and now to have that state
represented by a woman who calls Arizona
the meth-lab of democracy begs for the
rest of the country not to turn into
Arizona and then talks about how great
the Taliban is that is very sad that's
very troubling hopefully
it's just Arizona I mean you know it
seems that Kyrsten Sinema selection has
proved Kyrsten Sinema statements about
Arizona true hopefully this doesn't hold
true for the rest of the country and
look there are particulars of races I
mean certain candidates campaigned
harder have a better ground game have
better organizing but it's too bad
because you had a great candidate
mcsalley
and now she is over now broadly speaking
why would even Democrats even partisan
Democrats of the vote for a Taliban
apologist over a war hero well there is
a new study out today from Axio
SurveyMonkey which might give the answer
which is that 61% of democrats believe
the republicans are racist sexist and
bigoted 61% first of all kudos to you 39
percent of democrats who don't think
that thank you for being adults good job
but 61% the majority a strong majority
of Democrats believe that Republicans
are racist sexist and bigoted compared
to Republicans even now at the pitch of
the battle as hot as it is only 31% of
Republicans believe that Democrats are
racist sexist and bigoted and so you've
got less than there you've got about
about half roughly half the number of
Republicans as Democrats believe that
their opponents are racist sexist and
bigoted according to this study
one-third of Americans say that they
would be disappointed if a close family
member
married someone with different political
views a third of Americans I was
wondering about this because I thought
you know someday hopefully when it's the
day of my daughter's wedding I'm sitting
up like Don Corleone a in my office
granting favors to people and some lefty
comes in and he's gonna marry my
daughter would I be a little
disappointed I don't know it depends on
the guy I know
I know good left wingers I'm friends
with a number of left wingers probably
the majority of my friends are left-wing
just by virtue of the places that I've
lived so it depends on the person if it
were a Democrat who believes that all
Republicans are racist sexist bigots I
probably wouldn't like that guy but if
it fits a little bit more of a sane
Democrat that I guess that would be fine
but a third of Americans now say they
would be troubled by that the most
interesting part of this
survey is on the question of evil
because I actually understand the 1/3
answer I actually understand why 1/3 of
Americans would be troubled if a family
member married someone of the other
political party if you're in a situation
where the majority of Democrats believe
that Republicans are racist sexist and
bigoted then you're basically saying
that they're evil because in America
that's the worst thing you can call
somebody as a racist and to say that you
want to discriminate against people on
the basis of their skin you want to be
unfair to people you want to keep people
down you want to oppress people based on
immutable characteristics like race and
sex that's pretty wicked that's pretty
bad stuff so if you think that the other
person is evil probably you don't want
your little sister to marry that guy
however look at the breakdown the
question of evil because it asked
Democrats and Republicans do you think
the other side is evil so 61% of
Democrats say the GOP and Republicans
are racist sexist bigoted but only 21%
of them say that they're evil as for
Republicans 31% of Republicans think
that Democrats are racist sexist bigoted
but 23% of them think that they're evil
so you've got 31% and 23% that means
that you've got 8 percent of Republicans
who don't seem to think that being
racist sexist and bigoted is evil
compared to 40 percent of Democrats who
don't believe that being racist sexist
and bigoted is evil that number is
actually pretty interesting you've got
40 percent of Democrats who are they're
so quick to throw around those words
racist sexist this is status but they
don't really think it's evil they're
just using it they use it like water
they just I don't like you you're a
meanie and it shows how unserious ly
they take those questions how unserious
ly they take issues of racial
discrimination sexual assault they don't
take it seriously at all they bandied
about like nothing quite interesting
though how much more seriously how much
more evil Republicans consider those
sorts of things than Democrats that part
of the poll isn't being reported but
it's probably the most interesting thing
in there obviously right now we're it
were coming coming off of a midterm
election we've got a straw
president who is actually implementing a
conservative agenda and so tensions on
both sides are pretty high both people
are really turning the rhetoric up but
for Democrat for the majority of
Democrats to say that sort of thing
about Republicans shows you in what a
difficult place we are right now it also
shows you what a fantasy that were
they're they're living in what a total
fantasy in what country in what country
that offers affirmative action programs
for universities for private schools for
for the job market in what country that
is constantly boasting wonderful
diversity that is always dedicates a
month to black history dedicates days to
these great civil rights leaders what
that is constantly talking about this
that just elected the first black
president twice elected him twice in a
row how on earth is that country half
full of just dirty rotten bigoted
racists how how is that you know more
than half the country voted for Barack
Obama more than how it so how is that
possible it's obviously absurd but
they're living in this fantasy and
nowhere is this fantasy clearer then
when you talk to really rich celebrity
Democrats this Jada Pinkett Smith who is
Will Smith's wife she just did this
program called the racial divide between
women red tabletalk what you don't watch
it all the time this isn't your regular
viewing you go straight from The Daily
wire shows to go watch read table talk I
don't know she did this program it was
going around social media and she talked
about how much first of all she talked
about how much he doesn't like blonde
white women then she just has a
prejudice against them
I guess kudos to her for being honest
she should rectify that prejudice
because it isn't very nice but she says
she doesn't like blonde white women okay
but then what she said the most
incredible thing that she says is about
her own unfathomable oppression mrs.
Smith take it away
specifically in regards to my
relationship with white women the thing
that really breaks my heart is that
white women understand what it feels to
be oppressed
because what their seals exactly because
of this sex what it feels to be
ostracized or not being treated as
anything what she's talking about though
innit this interview is her oppression
oh she's shut so oppressed she's so she
doesn't understand you know white women
are oppressed - we're all oppressed by
the big bad I don't know
white straight male who thinks he's a
male of English descent probably not
even Irish because they got sort of
oppressed and this and that obviously
absurd hierarchies Jada pinkett-smith is
worth three hundred million dollars
she's worth three hundred million
dollars that is approximately three
hundred million dollars more than I am
worth I don't why my check my watch for
that I'm even I don't have my net worth
written on my wrist that is absurd but
she has to call herself a victim she has
to call herself oppressed why is that
why do these women they all do it they
do it in politics they do it in
Hollywood they do it at even levels of
business on the Left they do it because
what they want is the one thing that
their money just can't buy which is
victimhood victimhood has a social
currency now it's why everybody is
saying that there are some aggrieved
minority if not a racial minority if
they're not pretending to be one
one-thousand twenty-fourth Native
American then they will claim to be a
sexual minority or they will claim to
have been abused at rates that are much
higher than statistically it is possible
for people to have been abused they will
do this because victimhood carries a
social currency in our very sick culture
you think about Trumpy barre you think
about Teddy Roosevelt that these are
cultures that are promoting strength
that rewards strength and say you're not
a victim go out there be strong but
we're in a very broken culture now it's
especially clear on the left where the
more of a victim you can claim to be the
higher up the totem pole you sit the
better place that you can be in a lot of
celebrities are doing this even Michelle
Obama herself is doing this here is
Michelle Obama she's been doing this
book tour for her book becoming here is
Michelle Obama's take
on on her terrible oppression he's still
a law student at Harvard great a first
year first year you're going to be his
mentor yeah he comes blowing into town a
little bit famous already wait for the
first meet me late it's like is he
trifling the black man's gonna be late
on the first day like oh you weren't
overly impressed in the beginning I I
wasn't you know and I have my suspicions
when a bunch of white folks fallin on
over a black man because I sort of think
ok he can talk straight so they think
he's wonderful so did you catch that
what was that she says I have my
suspicions when a bunch of white people
are fawning all over a black man because
because of all the racism because of all
the racism that Michelle didn't Michelle
Obama go to Princeton or something she
goes I'm almost positive she went to
Princeton she was working at a good law
firm she's a First Lady of the United
States married to a future president
she's got a book deal she's one of the
most powerful women on the face of the
earth but she sees racism everywhere she
was doing this yesterday and her
interview too she was blaming racism for
any criticism of her of her husband of
the husband's presidency it was all
racism is because people weren't ready
to accept a black man in the Oval Office
people were more than ready to accept a
black man in the Oval Office I know
Republicans moderate Republicans but
nevertheless Republicans who voted for
Obama just to have the experience of
voting for the first black president I
know multiple people who did that
because they wanted to be a part of that
they didn't want there to be a racial
barrier to the presidency and so they
were even willing to stomach a lousy
awful president like Barack Obama if it
meant that you could get the first black
president so obviously blaming racism
for constantly Tariq harping on race
talking about race that's fine something
we've learned in these interviews that
is also going very unreported is that in
order to conceive their daughters
the Obamas used in vitro fertilization
and the reason I said look a lot of
people use in vitro fertilization
I have pals of mine who were conceived
that way so it's a fairly mainstream
procedure now
what's interesting is that the the right
wing has criticized Barack Obama rightly
for a great many things but they haven't
brought this one up because IVF is not
mentioned a lot in pro-life circles
pro-life focuses on how awful abortion
is and how many babies are killed each
year but they seem to overlook that in
vitro fertilization also destroys human
lives new human lives that are conceived
in vitro freezes them indefinitely or
kills them or implants them and then
when they're not wanted aborts them a
lot of people don't know about this I
think Catholics focus on this one a bit
more but a lot of other people in the
pro-life movement do not and they should
if you remember a number of years ago
there was that woman Nadya Suleman who
did in vitro fertilization she couldn't
get pregnant so they implanted 8 little
babies inside of her and typically in
that situation they would abort
whichever ones the mother didn't want
but Nadya Suleman is pro-life so she
just had eight babies and she became the
Octomom I suppose that's one one good
way to do IVF but in almost 100% of
cases it results in the death of an
embryo of an individual human life and
it's because it's so expensive to do it
that you need to create multiple embryos
or I suppose beget multiple embryos I
just have a chance for one or two of
them to take it you know I was trying to
wonder if this makes Barack Obama the
most pro-abortion president in American
history because he was running on it the
way he was talking on the campaign trail
he gave full throated support to
abortion a ton of taxpayer funding to
Planned Parenthood I mean he was he was
very very left-wing on abortion he
opposed bans on partial-birth abortion
he's about as pro-abortion
as you can get now I figured you know I
don't know John John F Kennedy was
pretty pretty loose with the women back
in the day pretty debauched there were
always some tales that came out that he
asked women to get abortions I don't
know about this but almost certainly the
IVF procedure involves taking a new
human life and ending it and I wonder if
the pro-life circles we're going to
start talking about it if conservatives
are going to bring that up or if they're
going to give it a pass but
cuz it's a little it's a little murky
for some people in the pro-life issue
because IVF is used to create new human
lives but it's so morally dubious
because it also results in ending human
lives we had a lot more to talk about
Facebook seems to have fired an
executive for supporting Donald Trump
and Ted Cruz completely identify this
and he totally called it and we should
have known it at the time also there are
other prominent conservatives who are
getting abused it's no longer just
politicians who are being attacked in
public it's commentators too and we know
exactly why that is also tonight at 7
p.m. you'll notice I'm not in my broom
closet or in the cave and Tora Bora
anymore I am in Milwaukee Wisconsin
right now I will be speaking tonight at
the University of Wisconsin Whitewater
the latest stop on my Yap tour we will
be discussing I think the most urgent
topic yet we've talked about a lot of
topics so far we've talked about the
simple joys of being right we've talked
about how to write nothing and sell
100,000 copies we've defended owning the
lives tonight I think is the most urgent
tonight we're going to talk about how to
be a man when you look like a madam some
people have told me I well I will get
into it tonight I'll get into it I don't
see the resemblance myself but we'll get
into it anyway so she good talk if you
are around there it's gonna be at 7:00
p.m.
come on over swell up the swell up fill
up those sweet sweet leftist news
tumblers come on out and you can also
catch me tomorrow night at Michigan
State University I'm just gonna be
jet-setting all over the place I don't
know maybe I'll turn up in your backyard
at some point you know lock your doors
closure closure shudders if you're not
on Facebook and YouTube right now you're
on The Daily wire thank you for
subscribing you helped keep the lights
on and Co FFA in my cup this is a sad
little Hotel Cup but usually I'd be
having a leftist years tumblr if you are
there you know it's ten bucks a month
100 dollars for an annual membership you
get me you get the employment show you
get the Ben Shapiro show it ask
questions in the mailbag you test
questions on the conversation you'll get
another Kingdom you get a lot of stuff
you at the leftist to Stumbler that is
all that matters I think if I'm not
arrested by the thought police in
Wisconsin I'm certainly going to wipe
whitewater raft out of here on the sea
of leftist tears so make sure you get
yours it's the only fda-approved vessel
for salty tasty leftist ears
and then come right back because we got
a lot more coming up
[Music]
according to The Wall Street Journal
Facebook has fired an executive
explicitly for supporting Donald Trump
and Mark Zuckerberg might have lied
about it in a testimony to the to the
Senate so the guy is Palmer Luckey he's
the co-founder of oculus you know oculus
is that virtual reality system which is
pretty cool it's the one where you you
know you feel like you're on the top of
a building and then you feel like you're
falling off and it's cool they haven't
really perfected the technology yet but
once they get the the graphics to be a
little bit better people are just gonna
plug into the matrix forever actually
the real thing is between the sex dolls
and once they get virtual porn set up
the human race actually will die out
within I think about six months I don't
think I don't think there's any hope at
that point between you heard there are
sex doll brothels now cropping up all
over the world so the human race is not
long for this world and basically this
guy is the cause of it but nevertheless
he's a conservative he's a trump
supporter his name's Palmer Luckey
he donated ten thousand dollars to an
anti Hillary Clinton organization during
the 2016 election this became public
this became a huge deal at Facebook six
months later he was out of the company
this is the co-founder of oculus
purchased by Facebook major guy rising
star in Silicon Valley he was at after
six months after this this came out at
the at the around the time of his firing
rather Mark Zuckerberg had to testify
about this and just watch how
masterfully Ted Cruz pulls what now
seems to be a lie out of Mark Zuckerberg
do you know the political orientation of
those fifteen to twenty thousand people
engage in content review no senator we
do not generally ask people about their
political orientation when they're
joining the company so as CEO have you
ever made hiring or firing decisions
based on political positions or what
candidates they supported know what was
Palmer Luckey fired that is a specific
personnel matter that seems like it
would be inappropriate he just made a
specific representation that you didn't
make decisions based on political
well I can commit that it was not
because of a political view what a
master some people forget because Cruz
is an elected official now they forget
that he's unbelievably intelligent that
he is wickedly smart what about one of
the great lawyer some our age and you
see what he did there he was talking
about the news curators on Facebook the
ones who were boosting left-wing causes
and deleting right-wing causes and this
became a little bit of a scandal so he
gets in there and he's got Zuckerberg
going down that train and he says do you
know do you know what the political
views are of those people so Zuckerberg
thinks that he's going down he says
absolutely not I never ask people their
political views he goes okay so as CEO
you've you've never made a hiring or
firing decision based on that Zuckerberg
at this point has to know that something
is up because he's just got diverted he
says well no no I haven't because of
what I just said before it's like right
then how come you fired that guy for
being a Trump supporter and it was just
this a beautiful knockout punch at the
time I remember washing and thinking who
is Palmer Luckey who what is Cruz doing
what does this matter it because it
didn't matter that it matters now that
we have it on tape this guy Mark
Zuckerberg lying through his teeth so he
says well I don't I won't comment on a
personnel matter I won't make a specific
statement on a personnel matter and then
Cruz just come then clobbers and kicks
him while he's down he says that you
just made a specific comment on a
personnel matter you just made a very
specific statement so it's okay well I
commit what what bizarre language from
Mark Zuckerberg I commit that I didn't
fire this guy Palmer Luckey because of
his politics I commit are you stating it
are you swearing it are you saying it
are you admitting it are you conceding
you commit and you commit a statement I
don't is obviously weaselly language
because Zuckerberg knew that he got
caught so any he's been caught now by
the Wall Street Journal internal emails
have shown that the upper echelon of
Facebook including Mark Zuckerberg we're
talking about Palmer Lucky's political
donation they were terrified of it they
were angry about it and they tried to
pressure him to change his public views
and then
they fired him they've got that there
was one woman and the engineering
director Sreenivas Narayan on said quote
this was in one of these emails multiple
women have literally teared up in front
of me in the last few days after Palmer
Luckey donated money to an anti Hillary
group well well if well if multiple
women have literally teared up in front
of you then I guess we should fire the
inventor of oculus for his political
views because oh because no I know it's
youth you think he has the right to his
own political opinions and he shouldn't
be fired for them and he has freedom of
speech and he can donate to whatever
candidates he wants no no no because
multiple women literally teared up in
front of shrinivas narayan on so he
should be deprived of his essential
rights as a citizen in the United States
that's the kind of logic going on at
Facebook right now and then afterward
Mark Zuckerberg pressured lucky Palmer
to endorse Gary Johnson why I have no I
mean what person on earth I couldn't
tell you but the trouble is lucky Palmer
loved Donald Trump he was a longtime
supporter of Donald Trump supportive
three years loved the art of the deal
he's one of the few people that's ever
read the art of the deal he said it
inspired him to become an entrepreneur
so he just loved this guy and he was
forced essentially to disavow him by his
employer under threat of being fired he
got fired anyway that's the kind of
abuse that's going on of conservatives
at companies around this country and
it's it's now infecting not just these
top CEOs it's affecting other executives
it's not just affecting politicians at
their homes at restaurants it's also
affecting commentators writers Talking
Heads there's that great girl cat Tim
who's at National Review I think and Fox
News as well she was just run out be
rated at a Brooklyn bar some woman was
threatening her at a Brooklyn bar over
the weekend why cat Tim would ever
degrade herself to go to a bar in
Brooklyn I have no idea but she decided
to do that for some reason and so as she
ended up getting chased out of the bar
for fear of a confrontation here's cat
Tim despite the progress that seemed to
be the hate on a very pop
late-night comedy show the fact that
matter is divisions are still real you
experienced it yourself right yeah over
the weekend I was at a bar and a girl
started she realized I worked at Fox
News started screaming at me telling me
to get out I tried to move to a
different area of the bar she kept
screaming at me telling me to get out I
kept trying to say like what did you
what did I say that you had a problem
with or maybe I thought it was one of my
views that was so offensive she said it
doesn't matter I don't think she knew a
single thing that I ever said on TV she
just knew where I worked and that was
enough for me to be run out of the bar
really did you did you walk out yourself
rather than just keep it going or what
happened I was afraid she was gonna hit
me or throw a drink on me she was super
belligerent like I said I tried to move
to a different area of the bar but the
yelling continued so I didn't really see
it as it as I had a choice man oh man
sorry to hear that guy I have left bars
in Brooklyn for far less than that so I
can sympathize but you know this is a
this is a relatively petite young woman
who's getting screamed at by some
belligerent woman who has guys standing
around her and the guys won't step in
the guys won't step in to protect this
girl who's scared which is awful in and
of itself we'll be talking about that
tonight in our talk on manliness and
feminism at University of
wisconsin-whitewater but the scary thing
for us is that now that now this has
gone down to the commentators and the
Talking Heads is not just cat temp
happened to Brian Kilmeade
it's happened to canvas Owens it's
happened to Charlie Kirk obviously it's
happened to Tucker Carlson on multiple
occasions his daughter has been screamed
at had horrible things said to her about
her father
someone tried to kick in and invade
Tucker Carlson's house kicked in his
door his wife had to hide in a closet
because she was so afraid of the
invaders this this is really bad news
because what do commentators and writers
and pundits what do they do they use
their language to convey some thought
about politics their job is free speech
the medium of their job is free speech
and this is what the left is so
horrified by it's what they're so so
terrified of is a free speech that's why
they kick conservatives off of campuses
when they get invited there it's why
they deny can
of professors tenure when they can it's
why they try to always boycott and get
right-wingers kicked off of television
or off of radio how many boycotts have
there been against Rush Limbaugh Media
Matters basically exists to shut down
Rush Limbaugh what are they so afraid of
why are they so afraid of free speech
how many times did those kids from
Broward County Florida david hog and
them try to get laura ingraham kicked
off of television for what why what are
you so afraid of they're not watching
the show the kids aren't why are you so
afraid that laura ingraham gets to say
what she thinks about the world they're
very afraid because they know that they
will lose in the battle of ideas they
don't have an argument they they don't
even have the beginning of an argument
they don't have the questions that you
have to ask to begin to formulate an
argument all they have is passion
angry passion and motive personal
politics the other guy's a racist
bigoted sexist evil I hate him and
that's all that they've got going for
them right now and so they have to cut
down free speech but it's really scary
not just for Brian Kilmeade or charlie
kirk though they can take care of
themselves but because of what it says
about the left's approach to discourse
in this country political violence of
all kinds is basically unfathomably bad
but one can imagine why a person would
would be angry and the sale and assault
a politician who is actually making laws
was actually governing the country I can
wrap my head around that what I can't
wrap my head around is why you rather
than refuting what somebody has to say
which would go out there and shut them
up and silence them and attack them it's
because it's because you have nothing
that you can you can say to refute in
the first place if you do have something
to refute those things that I'm saying
stop by the University of
wisconsin-whitewater tonight and we can
talk about it then I'll be back at
Michigan State tomorrow night in the
meantime I'm Michael Knowles this is the
Michael Nolt show I'll see you later
[Music]
the Michael Nolt show is produced by
seniya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austin Stevens edited by Jim nickel
audio is mixed by mic core Amina hair
and makeup is by Jeshua alvera the
Michael Knowles show is a daily wire for
word publishing production copyright for
word publishing 2018